welcome to the Sylvan lecture my name is
Mary Louise Timmerman's from the geology
and geophysics Department and before I
get started introducing our speaker
today I'd like to give you a little bit
of background on the silliman lecture
the mrs. Pepsi Eli silliman memorial
lecture series is the oldest at Yale it
was established in 1901 at the big quest
of her children
the annual lectureship was laid out for
lectures that quote illustrate the
presence and wisdom of God as manifested
in the natural and moral world and that
subjects should be selected from the
domains of natural science and history
with special prominence given to
astronomy chemistry geology and anatomy
the first lecture in 1902 was the
physicist and Nobel laureate JJ Thompson
who was credited with the discovery of
the electron
since then silliman lectures have gone
on to include Ernest Rutherford Niels
Bohr Enrico Fermi and a long list of
others the 1910 Sullivan lecture was
svante arrhenius who won a nobel prize
in chemistry and may be less familiar to
some of you of relevance to today's
lecture is that Irenaeus was the first
person to use principles of physical
chemistry to quantify the extent to
which the increases in atmospheric
carbon dioxide influence the earth's
temperature his paper came out in 1896
so around 120 years later we find
ourselves here at sea-level rise
inconvenient or unmanageable it's my
great pleasure to introduce today
silliman lecture professor Richard Ali
professor Ali is the Evan Pugh professor
of geosciences at Penn State University
he's world renowned for his research
advances in glaciology ice and climate
sea-level change and abrupt climate
change he has published over 200 highly
cited papers on these topics
professor Ali has many awards and honors
including election
to the National Academy of Sciences and
he's also an elected fellow of the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences he
was elected a foreign member of the
Royal Society in part for his
outstanding contributions to the study
of ice its interactions with the
landscape and it's linked to climate his
other awards include the Heinz award the
Seligmann crystal the Williston medal of
the Geological Society of London and the
National Center for Science education
friend of the planet award notably also
Richard was a scientific contributor to
the United Nations Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change which shared the
2007 Nobel Peace Prize so let's welcome
Professor alley it is an honor and a
privilege to be back at Yale it's been a
couple years since I was here and it is
truly really great to see you here I
want to John well au fer is an old
friend and Mary Louise is a new friend
and Margaret sent it up so I could get
here and and reserve the plane ticket
and so on so I'm gonna walk you through
what I hope is an interesting story I'm
gonna start with a little bit of big
background and I'm going to use
gratuitous penguins we the penguins
don't have anything to do with this but
they're fun so so at any rate I like
I've been to Antarctica four times
Greenland nine so so I do this stuff and
so we're gonna do some big picture with
penguins then I'm gonna do a little
economics then I'm gonna do a lot of ice
sheets and then I'll I'll close with
something okay so probably no one in
this room needs this little bit but some
of your neighbors Mike okay and I think
that we need to go back to basics a
little bit on certain things so the idea
that that we are here because we were
cured by scientific medicine or our
parents or our grandparents were that I
flew up here on an airplane that was
designed on a computer and it flew the
first time it was tried and it's still
flying you know I spend a lot of time
with this anymore there's a nice lady in
here she tells me where to go when I go
there and she's canoodling with Albert
Einstein because she knows where she is
because she has a GPS and that GPS
actually does use relativity and if it
didn't it wouldn't dump me in the bay
out here and a little bit the sound and
it's got quantum mechanics in there and
what is it this is a fascinating thing
go into a fifth-grade class and say what
is it no say it's your cell phone you
say what's it made of cell phone parts
what's it made of it's a little bit of
sand for the glass and the silicon and
the chip and it's a little bit of oil
for the plastic and it's the right rocks
the ones with the rare earth elements
and the palladium and so on and that's
all it is sand and oil and rocks and
science and engineering and a little
design and marketing and you know if you
talk the sand and oil into rocks and you
went down to the Senate and said here's
something do it yourself cellphone kit
right the randomly typing monkeys are
gonna produce Shakespeare before they
produce a cell phone but we have a whole
lot of fellow citizens who will take
this and send me an email that says you
scientists don't know what you're
talking about okay right so it is also
worth pointing out remembering that
science does advance and yes that cell
phone uses relativity and it uses
quantum mechanics a philosopher or
sociologist of science uses a computer
that that uses quantum mechanics but
they work in a building that was
designed with you Newtonian physics and
that airplane wing was designed with
Newtonian physics and when I model a
glacier I do not what right a quantum
wave function nor do I make a
relativistic calculation for the
velocity of the glacier I use Newton and
in fact to the best of my knowledge we
have never taken the useful parts of a
major body of sorry
it's real science and thrown them away
and when you meet the person who says oh
you scientists always change your mind
they're doing that in a building that
was designed with Newton now I'm gonna
go to energy for a little bit okay we
had some really good pizza down over
here today at lunch and we're going out
to dinner and I have a nagging suspicion
I will be over my 2,000 calories today
but in round numbers a human diet is
2,000 calories per person per day that's
the equivalent of a hundred watts right
so so I what you can do all the
brilliance that you do is the equivalent
of one bright old light bulb right and
if I actually had to make the light work
by riding a bicycle to make electricity
I'd be out of breath because that's sort
of all I can do but I flew up here and
the building is heated and the building
is lighted and and I did not have to
spend all summer hoeing corn so I don't
starve to death this winter in round
numbers the energy use in the United
States economy per person is about
200,000 calories per day it's a little
more than that so what I can do is one
what is done for me is a hundred right
ten thousand Watts take care of me and I
love this don't kid anybody it's great
but right now it's about 83% fossil fuel
all right so we live well because of
fossil fuels and that's going to change
the climate and climate science is old
and it is well established the lady in
my phone can pull signals out of the air
in part because there's filters in here
that go back to Fourier fourier is the
first one that figured out the surface
of the earth it's a little warmer than
it should be maybe there's something
acting like a greenhouse
18:29 identification of co2 as a player
and this is $10 a teen 59 mary-louise
mentioned a
1896 he basically got it right this is
all pre quantum making it quantum a lot
of it was done by the Air Force up the
road at Hanscom Air Force Base here
right after World War two they were
doing things like sensors on
heat-seeking missiles and co2 absorbs
infrared whether it comes from the hot
exhaust of an enemy bomber or whether it
comes from the Sun warmed earth and this
is just physics and there's really
nothing beyond that what a rainiest mist
was really how good oil and coal
companies would be at giving us what we
asked for
Arrhenius got the calculation more or
less right and then said now we'll never
burn that much right the amount of stuff
that we burn is fantastic all those coal
trains are full of stuff and when you
burn it it's still stuff and here's the
scaling you know what trash looks like
you can see that per person per year in
the United States we throw away at the
curb for the trash collector about a
half a ton right so thousand pounds of
trash per person per year at the curb
for trash collectors our share of the
co2 in the US economy is about 19 tons
half a ton of trash 19 tons of co2 okay
and this is changing climate and I could
give you that talk if you want I teach
the class I helped a little bit in
things on this but but this is happening
and it has impacts and it will affect us
and it's going to get worse over time
okay we have really good scholarship
that says if we use that with commitment
to doing it right with respect from
where we came from that not only is it
ethical and environmental not only does
it help national security and employment
but it also helps the economy using this
knowledge helps the economy right and
that's really important and we actually
know that with really high confidence
now I am
an economist okay I understand that that
bill is on the road a whole lot of what
matters in this field was done by
building hard houses here at Yale the
fact that he hasn't won the Nobel Prize
yet is just travesty in my personal
opinion he's fantastic he is a towering
figure but I'm gonna do a little
economics for you because I spent a lot
of my life studying changing ice
studying changing climate learning what
we could do to the world and having
people say oh it doesn't matter and it
doesn't matter because of economics and
so I'm gonna walk you through a little
bit of why people keep telling me that
I'm wasting my time and then I hope in
the end I'm gonna show you that I'm not
and that we can use this knowledge to be
even more valuable than we thought so
I'm gonna very briefly review some
economics and then I'm gonna take you
through some aishi collapse before we
quit okay so if you go and say the the
scholarship which says using this
knowledge makes us better off has in it
integrated assessment models of the kind
that the Nordhaus put together and those
models have built into them a few things
probably the big one the one that
dominates everything is that economic
growth is virtually assured the economy
will grow if we caused damages from
fossil fuels co2 that may slow it down a
little but not a lot the economy will
grow a big economy lets people in the
future solve any problems that we leave
them if it gets hot they can have air
conditioners if sea level rises they can
use bulldozers to make walls a big
economy solves problems now there's a
couple of others that are less important
but they're in there your grandchildren
are gonna be so much richer than you
that you don't want to sacrifice too
much now because it takes money from you
who are poor and gives it to them who
are rich and you people have watched you
people have watched us people have
watched our political process
and we act like we're a little more
important than our grandkids those are
probably not as important and then
there's a couple more down here Society
will respond efficiently when challenged
and we know what the economy will do we
know what nature will do it okay so this
is what goes into a model which comes
out and says using our knowledge makes
us better off so the thing is most of
the damages from our co2 are in the
future if we put up a lot of co2 it will
take nature sort of a half a million
years to get that down it will have big
effects for 10,000 years we are changing
the climate for timescales that are long
compared to the history of civilization
but that long term is really not
important in economic modeling because
the growth of the economy lets you solve
problems and so what happens is that the
future is economic is exponentially
discounted to the present for in the
future problems are not a big deal now
because we're in the future the big
economy will solve them and under the
usual sort of assumptions the usual
numbers that are used sort of the next
30 years matters and not too much after
that now it's not a cliff at 30 years
it's some exponential decay but sort of
think that we're worried about heading
off the climate changes for the next 30
years from our co2 and after that we're
not too worried about it and if you
really think the economy's gonna grow
fast maybe you are they only about 15
years but if you think the economy is
gonna grow slow maybe you worry about a
hundred years and that difference is
going to prove to be why ultimately we
need to know about sea-level rise so how
they do this then is to put this into
numbers and they say what is the present
value what is the present cost of the
future damages that will cause by
releasing co2 changing the
at melting the ice sheets and so on and
they call that the social cost of carbon
what is the cost of society of the co2
that I'm releasing and recent us
estimate per US tonne was $33 so my
share of the co2 19 tons times $33 600
bucks a year of damage that's done to
society that's not in the cost of the
fossil fuel right now there are there
are other estimates of this there was a
survey recently this is $115 a time in
which case I'm responsible for hurting
the society by $2,200 a year with my co2
and each of you is two so um so this is
sort of the way one one turns this into
a number and what it says is more or
less this the social cost of carbon is
the present value of the future damages
but you could think of it as a subsidy
for fossil fuels because they're allowed
to hurt the society and that's not
included in the price we pay for the
good we get we don't pay for the bad we
cost and so you could think of that as a
subsidy you also could think of that as
the profit that is waiting for society
if we make good policies or we invent
new things and in all the studies I know
of everyone that's now standing in the
IPCC picture there is a social cost of
carbon and that in turn means we can
help the economy with wise policies and
that's the really important thing if you
assume economic growth forever
is not going to be hurt much we're more
important than our grandkids you still
end up saying dealing with global
warming to reduce it will help the
economy now International Monetary Fund
has looked at this recently some other
people have the government is always
sort of involved with everything big so
they're reasonable involved with
renewables they're involved with fossil
fuels the conclusion of these studies
was that in the US and in the world
we subsidize fossil fuels much more than
we subsidize renewables and if you
notice that a lot of modern policies do
not take account of the social cost of
carbon then our policies act to
accelerate global warming but we would
be better off if our policies acted to
slow global warming and that's where we
can improve
ok and but we do include the social cost
of carbon in some decision-making you
will find for example this was a hearing
in February of this year that was
looking at how could we lower the social
cost of carbon so we would do less now
primarily what they tried to do was to
say well maybe we shouldn't count the
damages to the world but only the damage
is to us
and if each country only counts the
damages that their own co2 causes to
themselves then almost all the damages
are not costed and you just go ahead and
change the climate so there are efforts
going on in the world today to try to
lower the social cost of carbon so you
would do less now to head off global
warming why would you really lower the
social cost of carbon in a global
analysis if you think the economy will
grow really really fast so that our our
kids can solve the problems rather than
waiting for our grandkids then you would
do less now to head off warming if you
think we're really more important than
our grandkids or and I'm going to come
back to this if you're really certain
you know what the economy and nature
will do then you don't work as hard now
to slow warming but you still work to
slow warming in all of these analyses
we're still hurting ourselves by not
using this knowledge however if you're
worried that the economy won't grow real
fast or if you think maybe we should
give extra weight to future generations
or as I'm going to show if you're
uncertain about the economy then you
would do more now to slow global warming
you would work harder to read this
to emissions okay so here is a little
tiny analysis this is simplistic but it
may be useful
suppose that we know that that by
releasing co2 or something we're gonna
cause a thousand dollars in damages in a
hundred years
and we have to choose do we put our
money into growing the economy so our
rich grandkids solve the problem or do
we invest now in stopping the problem
and the usual sort of numbers people use
you should invest up to 20 bucks to head
off a thousand dollar problem in a
hundred years and if it costs more than
twenty dollars to stop that problem now
just put it in the economy and your
grandkids will solve it and that's the
better way forward you invest it grows
they're rich they deal with it so the
usual number is is something like that
and so to solve a thousand dollar
problem in a hundred years twenty bucks
now you can lower the if you say whoa
the economy is going to grow hugely so
we're gonna discount it greatly you can
lower that twenty bucks down to a dollar
but if you say whoa maybe the economy
will grow slowly that 20 bucks becomes
three hundred and seventy and this is
why I said uncertainty about the economy
notice that 115 the twenty is not nearly
as big as twenty two three hundred
seventy right so this is something if
our economics is uncertain it translates
into do more now to slow warming so if
you don't trust that we've got it
exactly right you do more now to slow
warming to reduce co2 emissions and
you'll hear people say oh we're
uncertain shouldn't we just wait there's
your uncertainty and the answer's no you
do more now and if this is the answer
all of a sudden whether that's a
thousand dollars from sea level rise or
ten thousand is really important and so
all of us
this says don't worry beyond about 30
years this says wow you better hire some
scientists and figure out what's going
to happen and so if we're uncertain
about the economy then our uncertainties
about science are really important and
we'd better know okay so I'm gonna take
you through one of the scientific
uncertainties and show you what happens
and how much better it could be too slow
co2 rise now to avoid something really
bad so that's where we're gonna go I
could do lots of others we can make by
late in this century we can make the
tropics in places uninhabitable for
unprotected people you know so there's
other things but I'm gonna do sea-level
rise so co2 gets high high co2 makes it
warm warm melts ice so these are a few
times in history this is high co2 hot
this is low co2 called this is high sea
level this is low sea level we're there
suppose we do the simplest possible
thing we connect the dots we take co2
today run it down to the line run it
over and ask where 10 percent of humans
live if we keep co2 high for a long time
in the past when co2 has been this high
for a long time
sea level has been higher than a lot of
people okay now that is not a prediction
it's not a projection but boy it's a
good reason to understand what we're
gonna do to the ice especially since in
a high emissions world we could
disappear over here we could crank up
co2 past sea level rise even a little
bit might be important so this is a
commercial picture Hurricane Gustav in
New Orleans did not get over the levee
it stayed behind the levee even a little
sea level rise there could be a big deal
but what we're going to talk about is
sea level rise out of this picture up
that way sea level is rising I spent a
while dealing with people right here who
wandered around saying oh you guys are
lying
all right stop they sort of shut up
about their sea level is rising okay
these are good data but at this rate it
takes almost a century to rise a foot
but if I take that and squeeze it down
so that's the previous plot and we show
back to 1700 the rise is accelerating
and our decisions determine where it
might go
however as I'm going to show you this
may be well optimistic and it's hard to
make it pessimistic so there's some
chance of something going way up there
so again economically that feeds into
the conclusion that dealing with this
wisely is good but there isn't too much
panic and the reason is first of all
that they're going to use something like
this for the rise and second of all
they're going to assume that we are
efficient and let me walk you through
efficiency for just a moment all right
so so you have a beautiful beach house
I'm not sure how you got such a
beautiful beach house but you sit on the
beach and you drink my thighs and you
watch the Sun go down and it's a great
beach house but you see the sea rising
so what do you do
you quit maintaining it when the sea
finally knocks over your beach house it
was just a hunk of junk we didn't lose
anything and you bought the house behind
him and when he's out of the way you
have the beautiful view the economy has
not lost the view all we lost was one
unmaintained beach house so the cost is
just dirt cheap right I have seen
published estimates that the
hundred-year cost to all the United
States of all sea level rise is less
than the cost of Hurricane Katrina
because what are efficient all right now
even so you still end up investing to
head off climate change we are still
hurting ourselves by not using our
knowledge but but you know will we
respond efficiently I was teaching
introductory geology before Katrina hit
New Orleans
it may be a few folks in here who were -
I think every serious introductory
geology course in America at some point
said you know C is rising
New Orleans is sinking because it's
built on a big pile of mud the
protective Delta is eroding the storms
might be getting stronger and that has
implications for reservoir engineering
if the ocean goes up and the city goes
down and the protection goes away you're
in deep doo-doo and we all knew this it
was government documents it was things
that everyone had so if we're really
truly efficient did this happen but it
did so I think it is worth asking
whether we're really as efficient as we
think we are right I I was at a meeting
on the economics of sea-level rise in
costs and and said ok the cost will be
we're efficient what's the worst thing
well we lose everything valuable near
the ocean that's not the worst thing the
worst thing would be well we pay a lot
to build walls keep the ocean out we
tell everyone they're safe we build lots
more valuable stuff and now we've built
valuable stuff more valuable stuff in
walls and then it goes under and we lose
it all
and if you think that's crazy you might
have seen this this was on NPR last year
new maps are like a bureaucratic magic
trick at the stroke of midnight the
federal government waived its lawn and
Friday morning more than half of New
Orleans woke up in a land safe from
storms and flooding for insurance
purposes
it's safe you can go build now you're
protected ok so so it is conceivable
that maybe we won't be quite as
efficient as we think in which case you
would tend to do more now to head off
climate change right now will the rise
be slow small unexpected is really the
question what will the ice sheets do so
right now glaciers in the mountains are
melting that takes water out of the Alps
and puts it in the ocean but when the
ocean rises about that much there's no
ice left and
Mountains the ocean is expanding because
it's getting warmer but that will take
centuries you know whereas it's actually
about 24 feet in Greenland and closer to
200 feet in Antarctica just on the same
scale if you know what the Lincoln
Memorial looks like if Greenland were to
melt and you start the water there the
water is in Lincoln's lap and if
Antarctica melts he's way underwater
this is I should put you on here I'm
sorry but at any rate this is less than
Greenland less than Greenland and
Delaware's pretty screwed you know
that's just Washington people laugh
about Washington but you know it's good
matter
superstorm sandy the biggest surge was a
little under 13 feet to 4 meters these
are feet numbers eight point nine feet
there seven point nine there seven point
nine there this is less than West
Antarctica even that's sort of West
Antarctica and this only stayed for a
few hours right so losing an ice sheet
is more than sandy for all the world's
coasts essentially forever and you
remember what sandy did it was a few
hours of that sort of matter you're up
here someplace
yeah just five feet right okay so and
you may see things like this would you
know and carbon choices determine US
cities committed to futures below sea
level we burn it all we could melt all
the ice but that's way in the future we
hope okay so let me do our Glaciology
class for you this Kurt Coffee Kurt
started at Penn State he's now a profit
Berkeley he wrote the book in our field
and so I'm going to review glaciology
for you really briefly and show you why
we might have to worry about sea level
rise being much higher and much faster
than we're expecting so this is my dear
wife her arm and she is making a pancake
she's trying to make a pile and what
happens if you make a pile
is it spreads under its own weight okay
that's the physics you need to know if
you hold it back somewhere it doesn't
spread as fast if you make it stronger
it doesn't spread as fast if you put it
on a bumpy or stickier bed it doesn't
spread as fast and it sort of looks cool
okay so that's the basic physics because
once an ice sheet snow falls it piles up
it piles up it piles up we used to get
mail from people who were terribly
scared of this though the Antarctica and
Greenland we're gonna grow and grow and
grow and the world was gonna roll over
it spreads under its own weight like
Cindy's pancake snow on top is connected
by flow to melting or iceberg making at
the sides if it snows more the pile gets
bigger the water came out of the ocean
and the ocean gets smaller if it spreads
faster to go melt or break off the pile
gets smaller and the ocean gets bigger
so that's the essential physics a
spreading pile and we worry about
strength and we worry about lubrication
and we worry about spatulas holding it
back so let me show you a little bit
about lubrication the edge of Greenland
where it flows on the waffle iron
underneath sometimes gets little hallows
in it and where it melts those hallows
get water and this is a lake and it's a
couple of miles across and it's 30 or 40
feet deep in the middle and it's been
growing you can see where the streams
were that have now been flooded by it
but it also has cracks under it water
can wedge open cracks so our former
student and now calling Sara das who's
down at Woods Hole went up to study
these things and she was in a different
lake but fortunately she was not on the
lake in her boat when it broke through
here she is in the lake okay so she's in
about there except it's not there
anymore
because it went to the bottom threw that
it was twice the Agra Falls for an hour
and it was dramatic and big blocks were
bouncing around and and you know in the
glacier lurch stop and it went sideways
and there was seismicity and it was all
exciting but the glacier didn't fall in
the ocean
here's air here's ice sarah was in there
where it drained through and why didn't
it fall in the ocean because it's a
waffle iron it's not a grease grill okay
so that matters but it doesn't matter a
lot but I'm gonna come back to that
because Sarah's like really will will
tell us something okay
spatula holds back the spreading pile
here's another analogy of something that
holds back the spreading pile this
building you don't have to worry about
the roof caving in and the walls bulging
out because it's strong it's like that
cooked pancake and the Newtonian
physicists who designed this do what
they were doing you don't have to worry
but the people who built early Gothic
cathedrals pushed this to the limit and
they had troubles with the walls bolting
out in the roof caving in and what did
they do they came up with the flying
buttress it does a spatula job of
holding back the walls by taking the
spreading tendency and deflecting it out
a nice sheet can have flying buttresses
- so here's the pile of ice it's minus
50 up there it's not gonna melt but if
it's cold it spreads down to the ocean
it spreads over the ocean still attached
it runs the ground and gets some
friction or it sits in a bay and scrapes
past aside and gets some friction but
this is almost melting and this is
melting so what happens if you were a
bad person and you wanted to hurt a
Gothic cathedral you might knock out the
flying buttress what happens if you
knock out the flying buttress of an ice
sheet right so I'm gonna show you
because this happened we're down here at
the tip of the Antarctic Peninsula right
there this is 12 miles
black is ocean these little icebergs are
immense this is the Antarctic Peninsula
with glaciers dripping down from it and
this is the flying buttress it formed
sort of 10,000 years ago as the ice
sheet shrank from the ice age maximum it
sat there for ten thousand years as of
January 31st 2002 but you remember
Sara's Lake see these blue things those
are it and remember this is 12 miles
these are big lakes in the cracks and
you remember what Sara's like that right
so let me make the labels go away and
then I'll make the ice shelf go away
this is five weeks and Sara's leg broke
through but it was sitting on top of a
waffle iron so it didn't fall in the
ocean this one just fell in the ocean
right and this blue slushy you could
kayak through it it's just broken up a
little bits of stuff now this was
floating so it didn't raise sea level
directly but you lost the friction you
lost the friction and like losing a
flying buttress this thing sped up about
eight fold now that raises sea level
because that's ice it was not floating
that's now going faster into the ocean
float now fortunately this didn't have
much ice behind it it can't raise sea
level very much so that one is just a
okay it's a warning this can happen what
we're worried about is these other ones
that have lots of ice behind them if
this goes south what happens let me show
it to you one more time we're gonna do
it in Greenland we're gonna come in
along this yellow arrow and look at it
this is the ice sheet of Greenland snow
on top spreads under its own weight out
to the edge pieces of it go a little
faster than other pieces and we
sometimes name them even though they're
just in the other ice and so right in
here is Jakob solvin glacier it's just
the piece of the ice sheet that goes
fast and it had a flying buttress it had
an ice shelf the ocean warmed one degree
the ice shelf broke off this was
probably the fastest glacier on earth
and then it tripled and it took nan
floating ice into the ocean and that's
contributing to sea level rise
so here's looking along that yellow
arrow tundra is over here tundra is over
here this is a very deep fjord fill of
water with broken up ice on top and the
ice sheet is coming towards you way up
at the top there and I'm going to show
you two pictures one is here the next
one is there the one here will show you
that there is water under this broken up
stuff here because that's a seal linked
to oceanography with these they put
instrument packages on they swim around
under the ice they come up they tell
ammeter what they observed which is
really cool and then the seal was down
here this is the big pile spreading
along and this used to be filled with
the flying buttress it's gone and that's
about a hundred meters it's a 30-story
building and then below it's about nine
times more because this is close to
floating so this is total about
two-thirds of a mile and there's the
Lincoln Memorial again for scale and the
next picture is gonna be right here I
was in helicopter with some senators we
were up there on a long weekend
observing and the pilot says how close
do you want me to get I assure you I was
not this eloquent but that's a 30-story
building hi those are 10-story high
cracks and if you walk down here under a
30-story building and you looked up and
you saw a 10-story high crack how close
would you get I said move it out a
little okay and what happens if you wait
there long enough is this right so
here's the 30 storey high thing there's
a Lincoln Memorial and here's the piece
breaking off right this is already
sticking up about 50 stories you're
gonna see a 50-story high splash right
so here it goes
right that's a 50-story highs flight
run it backwards this is so cool I'm
sorry I can just sit here and do this
alright we'll run it forwards again it's
just phenomenal
these things make earthquakes and you
could hear the earthquakes here right
magnitude five point something and so so
it they break off right in there it's
the Lincoln Memorial again okay but what
it does now is it breaks off and then it
waits awhile and then it breaks off and
you can fly by in the helicopter and
usually it doesn't get you and so but
you know if this piece this is a funny
plot so this is Antarctica the flying
buttresses are in cream the gray is
areas that if you took the ice off would
be land it's above sea level and all the
color is areas that if you took the ice
off it would be below sea level so it
can make icebergs but it also can raise
sea level because it's too thick to
float and what we're worried about is
this piece right here called Thwaites
glacier and if the weights backs up a
little then everything in here in color
will go and back in here it would have a
cliff that's way way higher than that
one in Greenland and higher cliffs can
break faster so we tried to do a little
programming I worked with Dave Pollard
in Rob Takano they're fantastic computer
modelers and we tried say okay suppose
we take this and we say when it gets
warm enough it acts like Greenland and
then how warm is warm enough we let a
little bit of the history of the ice and
sea level inform that so we just said
when it gets warm enough this acts like
Greenland and what happens then is once
it gets warm enough which may be 50
years out plus or minus 50 and then it
takes very little time to get rid of all
that and raise sea level up here about
15 feet short timescales all right and
they've actually they sort of said we
won't let it fall away too fast but it
could fall away faster than they did so
if you ever go
look at their numbers they're not a
worst-case scenario by any means and so
we might be late in the century be
expecting this much and yet you know
that much and if you think about what it
costs a little bit of rise they call it
nuisance flooding but at some point you
got to build a wall or abandon it and
then the wall has to be stronger if you
make it higher and so the costs probably
rise faster than the sea-level does
right and and so so let me do something
for you right I do not have to commute
by car but you might know somebody who
has to drive to the city so I want you
to think of some poor Schmo who's a
commuter and this is how much problem
they have and this is how likely it is
that they have it and what's the life of
a commuter you get stuck in the car
you're stuck in traffic you turn on the
radio and it's boring what is the best
thing that can happen to a commuter
there's no traffic and and you know you
get the Beach Boys festival right that
doesn't happen to you you get stuck for
an hour and they're testing the
emergency broadcast system all right but
there's somebody out there that just got
run over by a drunk driver and that's
why you're stuck in traffic for an hour
and we know that the most likely thing
is the way on the good end of what's
possible for a commuter and what do we
do right we buy a car with airbags and
crumple zones and anti-lock brakes and
now they have these new radar systems we
put the kids in child seats we support
mothers against drunk driving we have
police looking for the drunk drivers
we have highway engineers making the
road safer we spend a lot of our
transportation budget on things we don't
expect to happen because if they do
they're just so bad and we do that right
and if you start asking so if you use
this in your economic model it says we
will be better off economically if we
invest to head off global warming and
we're not now doing that according to
those IMF reports and yes there is
uncertainty the
future might be a little better than
that it's possible but we might dump
West Antarctica we might do a lot of
things that are surprising and could be
very very costly okay now I was in a
congressional testimony not that long
ago and I sort of said here's what we
know and we use this we're better off
and then they had someone who said Oh
couldn't it be better that's what we
know couldn't it be better this is what
we know couldn't it be better see we
heard both sides okay no no okay
there's more room to argue with somebody
who's really alarmed than with somebody
who isn't okay
so let me close up under the usual
assumptions efficient policies that
reduce co2 improve the economy as well
as employment national security attics
and environment if the economics are
uncertain then you tend to do more to
reduce and then you get into all the
uncertainties in the science and they
point the same way there's this
possibility of Ice Sheet collapse
there's possibility of other things it
could be very expensive and so investing
to head those off becomes valuable and
so economically using our knowledge is
good and improving that knowledge is it
good so I'll leave you with a picture I
took in Greenland can we have a world
with icebergs and rainbows yes we can
thank you
[Applause]
actual reports of what's actually
happening it goes along with it's worse
than predicted and I was wondering
whether that is because science tends to
underestimate rather than overestimate
because of political pressure yeah I I
suspect that we are careful so if you
did not hear the question is do we
underestimate our risks and I suspect
that we are indeed cautious I think that
sort of overstatement is considered very
bad but I think mostly it's actually
this that if you put up a best estimate
of what we expect and then you throw
darts and all the possible futures
there'll be more of them on the bad side
than on the good side and eventually
this just comes down to the fact that
it's easier to break things than it is
to build them and so you know I I
started you here what does it take to
build this what would it take to break
this I could just throw it at the wall
right it's easy to break and you start
thinking about could we build the Garden
of Eden by just raising co2 probably not
could we break things we care about
probably yes we expect every serious
analysis that I know of says that high
co2 will make plants happier because it
is plant food and that's built in we're
expecting that we're not as more alarmed
because co2 will make plants grow better
and maybe it's even a little better than
we're expecting but you can't make
plants grow infinitely fast because of
co2 people sometimes add a little co2 to
a greenhouse because the plants grow a
little better but not a lot and so most
greenhouses don't but if it gets too hot
your plants die if it gets too cold your
plants die if it gets too wet your
plants die if it gets too dry your
plants die my dad used to over fertilize
my mom's flowers and kill the plants
that way if your pollinator
don't show up it's as bad as the plants
dying you don't have a crop if the
invasive smut or the invasive virus or
the invasive whatever comes in you lose
your plants so what do you expect it
could be a little better it could be a
little worse or a whole lot of them die
right it's easier to break than it is to
build and so the waiting tends to be on
the bad side and so if you then say okay
is that what we expect that or is it
worse
usually you'll get worse and I think we
just need to remember that that the best
estimate is often well on the good end
of what's possible right so I think
technically there's no doubt that we
could pull billions of tons of co2 out
if you think what goes in now to our
fossil fuel system and all of the
fracking and all the oil wells and all
of the tankers and all the pipelines and
all the gas stations and all of that
you'd think of an infrastructure that
was similar or a little bigger because
the co2 is bigger than oil is and so
whether we'll do that whether anyone
could take the actions and get it
together politically and invest in it
right now the assumptions the economic
models tend to say that's easy because
your grandkids are rich and they can
deal with it so you'll find a lot of
models so when you say find us an
optimal path to not get too hot they put
the co2 up and then let our grandkids
take it down again but but would they do
that and could we possibly once you
start taking it down you now have to
agree where you're going and so somebody
you know would would Russia and you
again they get together and say we want
to take this much out to get to this
temperature and is that
plausible future and might have some
friends who are hydrogeologists and you
know if you put the poison in the
groundwater you can take it out you can
pump and treat and sparge and all these
other things but if you actually ask a
serious hydrogeologist what's easier
take it out or not put it in they don't
like take it they like not putting it in
so I suspect and it's actually much
easier not to worry about taking it out
but I think we could and I think if we
got desperate enough we would at the
point where going outside and sitting in
the shade drinking water naked with the
wind blowing and you're gonna die
because it's too hot we'll do some right
so two degrees is probably possible
again we sort of get there by taking
some co2 out if we got really serious we
could probably do it but we're getting
close
tipping points I served a little bit
bill Nordhaus and I served on the first
Academy panel that looked at abrupt
climate change tapping points and then I
served on the second one they probably
are physical ones that ice sheet is
probably the most important one they're
probably our biological ones you get to
dry the forest burns and a grassland
comes back and you just lost it and it
might have been the Brazilian rainforest
or something they're almost certainly
our societal ones and this may be what's
really important so we know that there
was a paper a couple years ago in the
Proceedings National Academy
human-caused climate change has made
droughts more likely in places including
Syria and we doubled or tripled the
likelihood of the drought a drought
happened did we cause it we
doubled or tripled the likelihood and it
happened so we loaded the dice to come
up drought it came up throughout Israel
did not break out in the Civil War
Lebanon did not break out in the Civil
War Syria it was a straw that broke the
camel's back and I think it's fairly
widely agreed that the last it was an
unhappy place it lacked resiliency the
drought had and okay now that was a
tipping point the there is a dotted line
in which some of our military leaders
have identified between heat and drought
in China and Russia and rising bread
prices and the uprisings in North Africa
that's a point and we probably have a
lot of tipping points in our societies
and whether economic growth is
completely proof against such tipping
points I think is a question that's
worthy of further consideration so yes
here and then
[Music]
okay so what would I do if you put me in
charge I you know I'd give it somebody
else immediately you know me running
anything but but I think that the first
thing you know I have been deeply
influenced by by Bill Nordhaus and the
first time I testified to the
subcommittee in the US Senate it was
chaired by a Republican who really I
believe wanted me to scare the heck out
of people so that you could use a an
economically conservative approach to
this by putting a price on emissions so
rather than trying to outlaw things
rather than trying to regulate things
rather than trying to squeeze the
balloon
you just put a price on and let it go
and I I've heard this enough from from
dr. Nordhaus and from many other people
that across all the serious economists I
know they like a price signal is the
best way to do this and then I think you
spend a bucket load of money on
engineers and Applied scientists who are
gonna solve the problem and this is
gonna be electric grids and it's gonna
be better solar cells and it's gonna be
windows that collect solar energy and
it's gonna be how do we integrate
batteries in public cars into the
storage system and it's going to be all
the the things that the evidence is
clear that we can build a renewable
energy system that it will power
everyone essentially forever that will
get rid of all these side effects it
will end up in an economy which is
better in an environment that is better
that can give everyone the energy that
we now enjoy and the transition to that
is going to be a pain in the butt and
you know when we transition from being
hunter-gatherers to being farmers it
sort of took us 10,000 years when we
transition from being hunter-gatherers
of energy to being farmers of energy we
can do it 30 rather than 10,000 but it's
gonna be a pain in the butt so I fund
that and then I probably I don't know my
third one if he gave me three whether it
would be artists and
people whether it would be sort of
getting us back to we can do this and we
can make the future better educators who
can tell the good news as well as too
bad but I also maybe these tipping
points won't happen and funding our
community of scientists to tell you how
much to panic about the future could buy
you a little time and so I suspect it's
a broad area of community and purpose
building that includes some knowledge
but but get started on the solution
space and get started on the price
signal that makes that solutions you
know on the scale like I said on the
scale of panic about global warming to
do nothing about global warming what the
reports say is we're over here on make
it go fast yes right so carbon dioxide
has raised from sort of 280 to four and
a little bit so yes we have raised it so
the statement is the temperature rise
has been way less in fact the models are
doing beautifully so if you go back to
early work you go back to the Henson 88
you go back to a bunch of things we're
spot-on the reason that we haven't seen
so much rise is right now a huge amount
of heats going in the ocean and so if
you turn up the heat in your house on a
cold night
you start heating the air and then
immediately it loses heat into the walls
in the bed and the furniture and it
takes a while to warm it up we're way
less than where we're at where we are
committed to more warming than we've had
yes absolutely so we are committed if we
stopped right now we get some more
warming which is why we're so close to
2c already is that we we already you're
absolutely correct yes yeah
it's relationship to carbon pollution
and is it something that you're willing
to talk about right so population growth
it is our impact on the world is impact
per person x number of people and so
this is easy if you want to reduce our
impact either reduce number of people or
you and those impact per person so
there's no question that population
growth would be one knob you could turn
there's also no question that you know
if we go on an exponential growth at
some point all Exponential's have to
turnover right we're not going to have
people standing this way on the whole
world
so so but there is this optimistic view
okay and now let me let me do this right
so what we know with fairly high
confidence based on observation this is
not physics this is not F equals MA but
what we've seen is that people tend to
choose to replace themselves and not
more if those people have confidence
that their kids will grow up interesting
things to do and some control over their
reproductive lives and if we give that
the people so so confidence that their
kids will grow up interesting things to
do in some empowerment of women the
projections are that the world
population stabilizes and it stabilizes
without anyone doing anything else so no
one has to go in and do a one-child
policy or anything of that sort that
people choose when they're doing okay if
we don't provide that all Exponential's
have to turn over and whether they turn
over that way as a real question and so
the sort of issues if you want to ask
long term how do we how do we do well
for sustainability health of children
including health the children in the
third world helping empower people
education and if one had to choose a
bias my reading of the scholarship
is that you have to make sure it gets to
women you have to empower women and I'm
not an expert in this and if anyone
wants to jump in I would would wouldn't
seed but my understanding is that you
have to make sure of that
[Applause]
[Music]